you got to want it if you want to have
success as an entrepreneur you will have
to want it if you're just trying to make
a little bit of money you're kind of
putzing around doing the same part time
and you're not really committed to it
you're not going to have success you
have to want it or it's not going to
happen for you hi I'm Evan Carmichael I
believe that hungry entrepreneurs
deserve help and today makes them a
question from one of my readers no rain
I hope I pronounced that properly wanted
some advice saying I would like some
help please elaborate for me what
qualities that should be possessed by an
internet marketer thanks for the
question great question and I don't
think it really matters what type of
entrepreneur you want to be doesn't
matter what business you want to start
if you want to have success as an
entrepreneur the three main tips I have
few guys here we go get ready for the
gold the first you have to follow your
passion you gotta do something that you
love doing something that excites you if
that's internet marketing great go for
it learn everything you can about it
dive into it you want the type of
business that you can start at nine in
the morning and it's five o'clock at
night II you didn't realize we're all
the time when it because you love it so
much it's not all roses it's not all
great but you love doing what you're
doing okay that has to be number one to
model success find someone who's already
done what you're trying to do put their
strategies to work for you if your
internet marketing go find out who the
top internet marketers are in the world
and all these guys have blogs and
YouTube channels and they talk to what
they're doing and learn from them don't
make all the mistakes yourself learn
from other people's mistakes and learn
from their success whatever goal you
have in the world someone has already
accomplished it find that person learn
from them and put it to work for you you
are going after internet marketers it's
easy to find these guys online go find
them learn will work for them apply it
to your business and the third thing my
third tip is don't quit if you love this
if you want it if you're committed to
this you can't quit when it's hard when
life sucks when you're not making money
when you're thinking about giving up you
have to keep going you have to go one
more day each time you have to go one
more day if you love what you're doing
and you're helping people you have to
keep going you can't let it hold you
back because you're going to go off
having to go get a job and look back on
your life and wish that you tried harder
and I don't want you to live with that
regret if you don't like what you're
doing if you're doing it just to make
money fine kill it go on to something
else but if you love what you're doing
and you know you're helping people you
have to keep going and find a way to
make it work you were to yourself you
were to your family you're with your
community you would to the global
community otherwise you'll live the rest
of your life with regret good luck those
are the three things follow your passion
model success don't quit for those are
you are watching if you liked the video
please give a thumbs up below makes me
to do more for you and hey I want to
hear what you have to think please leave
a comment underneath this video I love
seen those come in while I'm eating my
breakfast every morning it's a highly of
them are day so please leave a comment
and if you have a question for your own
business leaving a comment section below
I'll read it I'll make a video apply for
you thank you guys I'll see you soon